[Music]
so occasionally as i'm on the internet i
stumble upon an article that
that i love you live on the internet i
do live there that is my zip code and uh
occasionally i find articles that i love
that i think would make you angry and so
those are the ones i want to read on air
great let's do you ready for the
headline john this sub's fun just so
america knows john does not know what's
about to hit him absolutely nothing no
idea what's coming bring it here's the
title love is in the air so is dander
on december 4th 2021 twixie and cowboy
both two-year-old brussels griffins were
married at the dallas home of the bride
twixie in the backyard
she wore an appliqued lace bodice with a
ruffle of layered tulle at the waist
george are these the groom i'm not done
john
the groom donned a handmade silk cotton
tuxedo and top hat later four-legged
guests enjoyed a meal of puppy chow from
vestal's catering in dallas as well
get this john as a puppuccino bar and
activities including a ball pit
the nuptials
cost about 25 000 what community was
this in dallas your home state john be
proud the two in their canines met at a
brussels griffin hangout in february
2021 the dog soon became boyfriend and
girlfriend no they didn't miss wilson
who handled the guest list said that she
and mrs hellwig intended to throw the
most epic dog wedding you know what i
guarantee you is in that community
hungry people
and dogs hungry dogs and
puppy chow was provided we have entered
a tiny little vortex that we're not
going to be in much longer george where
we have more money and access to capital
than we have since i wish this was an
april fool's joke but this is from march
16th from the new york times oh gosh
so uh how do you feel about dog weddings
john i think we need to put that out
there because i think we're gonna see
more of them happen i think this show
needs to be
sponsored by preparation h because i've
got hemorrhoids now
i cannot believe
i i just i didn't have the words for it
i don't even have the words for it um i
don't believe in love for dogs um i love
can dogs find love nope they can't they
mate they mate george you wanna can i
get insulted
like
this is somebody living out a fantasy
that clearly didn't happen in their life
and they are putting it on their poor
dog you know what that dog was thinking
the whole time treat treat treat and
they said sit and the dog was not
thinking wow she looks beautiful coming
down the dog aisle he was just thinking
treat treat treat don't pee don't pee
don't pee treat that was it that was all
that was in that dog's head
and at one point when he was being
squeezed into the tuxedo he thought
i don't like my owner but treat treat
right that's it
you're telling me you don't want to see
those instagram pics nope okay
you know i'd rather see i'd rather see
people uh giving money to a food bank
just enjoy life man can't people have
some fun
you're gonna get your uh your little
mutant dogs married aren't you that's
right i've got two french bulldogs but
technically they're related i feel like
i don't know
i'm not going to get them married
they're super not related insult to
injury because they're dogs and b they
came from different litters can i make
you even angrier
we saw this ad
that popped up someone sent it to me
from after pay here's what it said let
your fur baby say i do with after pay
which means you can now it's right there
on the screen from matching outfits to
snacks at the dog park reception you can
now pay off your pet wedding in four
interest-free installments with afterpay
there's no such thing as a pet wedding
here's this it's not a thing i don't
know if that was an april fool's joke
but i'm scared that it will become
reality
there's no such thing
there's no such thing as pet parents
you're you're pet owners and listen i
love my dog my wife had to have a talk
with me
about um when we got married
and i told her that dog was in my bed
long before you were right i loved my
dog i love my dog the dog i have now my
dog stella
is my ride or die dude
i get it
but i'm a pet owner i'm not a pet dad i
am though a human dad because i have
human kids
and when they have weddings you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna take uh
human wedding photos and we're gonna
throw human wedding rice i don't know
what we're gonna do but whatever they
want to do
we're not gonna throw
so i'm guessing my dogs are not invited
to your kids weddings and there will be
no puppuccino bar there will
not
that's offensive you know it's offensive
puppuccino
the people at starbucks are sad about
that what is a puppeteer it's fun they
just called it a puppetino if you go to
starbucks fun fact you have your dog or
if you don't you ask for a puppuccino
and they give you a little cup of
whipped cream and it's a little treat
for the dog and it's called a puppuccino
i can get behind that yeah that's all it
is no need to get angry i don't think we
need a puppuccino bar if it's just a can
of ready whip that's true
spray it
wow well uh the only insult injury there
john is not only are dog weddings a
thing but now you can go into debt with
buy now pay later for a dog wedding
so i'm kind of this eternal optimist i
just think things are going to work out
people are going to come together and
there's i get these i get these these
shards of
of uh
apocalyptic sightings
and these are one of those moments where
you go it could all just come crying i
think it's coming down and then by this
afternoon i'll be good to go and um
then i'll see some young kid texting and
driving and i'll think nah it's probably
gonna come all down and then uh somebody
will send me a clip of this actual
conversation that you and i are having
about uh dog weddings
it's all cool i'm pretty sure it's in
revelation sign of the end times
dog weddings no it's the puppuccino
that's what it is chapter four versus
wow wow good times there john well i'm
glad i upset you mission accomplished
and thank you producer james actually
everything's upsetting you
no just don't
i don't understand you it's fine john
let's get to the phones man no one wants
to hear about dog weddings anymore